hello everyone the Cote d'Ivoire rapid
and blitz tournament is over in Abidjan
but we said we will cover a few more
games and this is one of the more
exciting ones a lot of we have requested
it
Maxie Marshall DeGraw with the white
pieces I can see Cara Nakamura really an
excellent game it's really really a game
in two parts a game with a story if you
will but it's it's just amazing how how
far one preparation can go
especially for a blitz game so as usual
we will not to be overanalyzing it due
to being a blitz game but it's still
just amazing so without further ado
let's check it out Maxime opens with E 4
and Nakamura goes a 5 we will have the
Berlin which makes it all the more
exciting
we have Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to b5 and Knight to f6 the brilliant
defense a line of the rule opus is on
the board and it's always very exciting
for the chess world when new poison is
is added in any line of the Berlin with
castles by Maxime Knight captures on e4
and now just the d4 the standard line
Knight to b6 with Bishop captures D
captures and now just pawn captures on
e5 Knight to f5 we have the early Queen
trade on move 8 as is often often the
case in the Berlin and now h3 and here
we have King to e8 a standard idea
Knight to c3 with h5 and now comes a
bishop to f4 with Bishop to e7 route 81
and the now comes Bishop to e6 so here
it's a pretty a pretty standard position
and we have Knight to g5 by Maxine now
going after the bishop here which would
go very nicely if you could mess up the
black's pawn structure create several
pawn islands here we have rook to 8 6 by
Nakamura now if if Knight captures the
rook is defending the bishop already and
just look after a one a nice developing
move and here
Bishop to b4 just spinning that night
here Nakamura wants the capture mess up
Maxim's pawn structure and well
as the white it does have a lot of
pressure against the black king still
being in the center nakamura wants to do
something about it so we have a three
even forcing this exchange Bishop
captures be captures and now h4s or h4
by black and it's very interesting that
Maxime so far hasn't wasted any time on
his clock he's I want to say blitzing
out but it's more like he's playing
bullet so he's spending no time on his
clock we have nice day four and now
comes the idea this night wants to come
to c5 but it will all be revealed very
soon we have looked to g6 by Nakamura
and now comes g4 here with H captures in
g3 on bass on F captures and g3 and now
Knight back to e7
and here comes h4 so this is the idea
and where the game basically really
starts the but maxime still not wasting
any time this is still everything
everything within his preparation even
though we are already unmoved 20 and
Nakamura time on the clock is well
dropping very quickly we have Knight to
d5 you do have to create some room for
your look if h5 comes it's gonna be very
uncomfortable so we have Knight to d5
first threatening to capture on f4 and
now comes the Bishop to g5 really
limiting the movement of Nakamura's rook
h5 now the threat of capturing the rook
so we have Bishop to f5 now clearing the
e6 square for Nakamura's rook but with
h5 nonetheless so what's the point if
you go rook to East 6 and then Knight to
c5 traps the rook anyway it's not really
well not try Brooke but you will win the
exchange so yeah it's a pretty big deal
so after h5 Nakamura loses some time on
the clock and he finds that Knight
captures in c3 ok you capture my rook
I'm gonna capture your rook here maxine
goes h captures in g6 with Knight
captures and e1 and here I'll give you a
couple of seconds just to check out the
position just to see how much
preparation went into Maxime into this
game so this is already moved to 23
we're going into move 24 and Maxime
still well within his preparation try to
find a nice move for white here and then
you will see what Maxime played with the
white be
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to find
some of the most congratulations but if
you found the move Maxime played then I
simply don't believe that you actually
found it because it's really just
ridiculous
here there are a few options obviously
you could go route capture some d1
that's the most straightforward one so
we're gonna explore that one if rook
captures then you get Bishop captures on
e4g captures on f7 King captures on f7
and now rook to d7 check King to e6 you
would get a rook captures in g7 and now
after rook captures in c8 defending it's
a it's equal position but you will not
be able to prevent both King captures an
e5 and Bishop captures and c2 so black
well although he does have a CC pawn
it's actually black who will be up upon
so not something well not something
spectacular for white obviously not
something we've seen prepared
so after Knight captures on d1 this
doesn't work what about G captures on f7
a lot of you probably consider this idea
also an excellent client if G captures
on f7 King captures on f7 now comes a
six with check and now you see the
beauty of this King to g6 now comes
route capture some d1 rook to e8 and now
comes East 7 just defending that pawn
with Bishop captures on e4 first rook to
d8 now hoping to win the rook or rook
captures and then white gets a queen
into the game but now just came to f7
and white has no ways of making progress
here everything's defended it's a you
know there are bishops of opposite
colors so you will not be able to oppose
each of them and again there's no way
for whites to make progress here so what
did Maxine play here that makes this
game so incredible and how far his
preparation goes here Maxime played King
to g2 and now it's it's black to move so
what do you play here with black
obviously there are a lot of a lot of
possibilities the problem is if you play
something like f captures and g6 it
creates a lot of problems for black but
we're gonna cover that for example just
to give you an idea if you just go for
something like Bishop captures only for
rook captures on e4 Knight to c3
attacking the rook now comes Luke to a 4
and f captors on g6 now white pushes
well white pushes East six and it's all
over here the pawn controls d7 and f7
and the bishop controls c7 and there's a
really no good way of defending against
rook to h4 followed by rook to h8
checkmate so this is this is the idea if
this pawn ever leaves the control of
these six square this point comes to e6
all of these are covered and it's well
checkmater will soon follow well not
checkmate but severe material loss
either way so after this King to g2 move
with the shock captures on g6 not
allowing this beautiful idea maxime had
button magazine finds another nice idea
and of course that is nice to see five
he still finds way to control at the b7
e7 and now the f7 square is covered by
the points obviously you're still not
gonna be able to cover that and if you
just push something like this then it's
not not really gonna make a difference
so here you have to make a choice
against again all of these squares are
covered now Luke to H 1 followed by rope
to h8 checkmate is is the idea but also
just winning the knight on d1 it's
perfectly fine so here Nakamura tries b6
he wants to trade nights and here just
night to a6 and now there's no way for
Nakamura to defend against the threat of
Knight captures on c7 which would of
course win the rook here as you can see
and also just route capture some be one
wins apiece
so here Nakamura goes rook the c8 and
now comes rook captures and d1 so
grabbing up upon and if that is sort of
grabbing a piece and if that's not worse
as you know bad enough after Bishop
captures on c2 where Nakamura played
here we have Knight captures on c7 with
Czech and now you see if rook captures
rook captures and d8 is checkmate so
that's that's really really insane of
course the rook cannot capture Nakamura
plate came to f8 and now we have looked
to da check Maxime is up a piece of why
not just straight rooks we have rook
captures Bishop captures and now just
Bishop to d3 and the camera wants to
take this position to prevent any six
ideas but now if you look at the
position Maxine has a bishop and the
knight and three points well
has a bishop and five points so two
points for the piece it could be some
compensation but usually usually it's
not unless you know the position of the
king is great which is which in this
case it's not you can see that the
bishop and tonight create a wall against
the black king so the black King isn't
really even able to enter the game it's
not going to be easy and if this was a
classical game or even a rapid one it's
hard to say well if it was rapid III
don't think Nakamura would resign but if
it was a classical I think there's a
fair chance that we would see a
resignation here but since it's a blitz
game you know there's always chance and
if anyone can do it it's Nakamura so
let's see how how this continued with
King to f3 and this is why I say it's
game in two parts this is just a
beautiful preparation that basically
lasted for 30 moves in the Berlin I
really just insane Maxime came really
prepared as you can see with the
brilliant and also with his night off
crushing Magnus Carlsen with it so King
to f3 we entered the second part of the
game which is now basically if you have
the technical skill to convert a winning
endgame into a full point or in this
case full two points as they are
awarding two points for a win but okay
Bishop c4 with g4 now this prevents East
six with g4 Bishop to f1 Nakamura just
wait and see what Maxime will do with g5
Bishop back to d3
King to III attacking bishop f1 now
comes g6 he wants to get rid of this
pawn so he can start pushing this pawn
of course if if this happens just east
six will we knew the game there's no no
way of stopping this so not an option we
have Bishop to h3 and now comes G
captures sorry G captures on f7 by
magazine King captures on f7 and Bishop
to g5 now we have Bishop to c8 now comes
King to d4 Bishop to d7 King to e4 and
now comes the bishop to see it Nakamura
has nothing to do he just waits and see
what Maxime will do with King to f4 and
now comes the Bishop to d7 and here
Knight to a six we have keep the e6 King
to e4 and now bush of the c8 attacking
the knight night before with c5 Knight
- eh - and now comes a bishop - b7 check
with King to f4 and now be 5 so Nakamura
definitely making some progress
he made Maxine's night as passive as
possible and if he starts pushing those
pawns it could get a bit dangerous for
Maxine with Knights to see one now comes
came to d5 of course Nakamura wants to
activate his King as much as possible I
will Bishop to e7 and now comes a five
so the pawns are marching forward with
Knight to b3 here Nakamura basically
offers upon as you're gonna either lose
this one or this one so he plays c4
Knight captures on a4 and now comes
Bishop to c8 just getting the that
Bishop out of the way and here Nakamura
wants to start pushing his own past
pawns so here Maxime plays Bishop to b4
to prevent it but now comes g5 by
Nakamura finding resources in so little
time he explained all of these moves
with only a few seconds on his clock
King captures and g5 and now King
captures on e5 getting rid of this very
strong passed pawn with Knight to c6
this comes with check King g4 and now
King to f6
so Maxime still up a piece but now it's
two points from Nakamura against only
one pass point from magazine our win
here is becoming well and not not all
that probable with King to be three
nights the e5 check with King to d4 and
now comes Knight back to c6 check King
to d3
now comes King to e5 and now c3 Nakamura
again starts pushing his passed pawn
with Knights to d4 we see - and the
Knights the b3 a very important maneuver
as now the knight controls the queening
Square but also the bishop can now move
as the knight also controls the d2 score
so the king will have to make quite a
detour to reach the C 1 square probably
even through c4 which can Nakamura does
with King to c4 and if if King to e2
then also just Bishop to b2 is very
strong just controlling the queening
square also the knight now controls the
bishop so we have King to c4 now comes
Knights to c1 and Bishop to g4 with King
2f
attacking the bishop bishop to age five
and now kink the III with Bishop to g6
King to d2 now the night we'll enter the
game and the the White King will start
blocking the pawn with Bishop to a5
Knights that e to and now comes the
bishop back to g6 and just King c1 with
Bishop to d3 attacking the knight Knight
f4 and just push it back to a five so
now Nakamura's plan is to just move the
bishop back and forth and if at some
point this White Knight even captures
the pawn it will not matter because then
just Bishop captures and well it's it's
not gonna matter because even if white
wins this point this point is of the
wrong color and you will not be able to
win the game if anyone doesn't know what
that means we're gonna explain it a
little bit later with Knight to G to
butter up to g6 now comes Knights the
III check King to d4 and now Knight to
g4
we have Bishop back to f5 attacking the
knight Knight f6 and now comes came to
e5 nights the I ate and now kink to d5
so for the moment nakamora keeping a
very sturdy defense maxime not and not
able to break through with King Toby -
now comes King to c6 and now Knight to
g7 attacking the bishop bishop to e4 and
now bishop the back to D do so now the
bishop will guard the queening square
and the king will start gaining activity
King the six we have King to c3 Bishop
back to g6 and now comes King to d4 king
te 7 trying to trap Maxime tonight and
now comes King to e5 it's interesting if
if you try something like King to c5 to
get rid of the point immediately then
king f7 will trap the night if you try
something like Bishop h6 then just you
Queen Queen the pawn Bishop captures and
you eliminate this night king capture
son b5 and now the bishop will be able
to guard e8 square it's not a problem
it's a clean draw so after King to e5
not allowing this so now the knight can
escape with Russia back to h7 Knights
the e6 and now comes King to d7 and here
we have a very exciting moment where
Maxine can go for night so in fact to a
faith check
and the reason Nakamura loud it is
because it's very tricky and it's very
interesting it's a completely winning
move but Maxime doesn't go for it
because both of them are getting very
low on time well Nakamura is a long time
all the time Maxime does have a bit more
time but it's really complicated if
Knight to f8 check King to c6 yes you do
win the bishop but now comes King to c5
and now what do you do Knight to f6 you
try and bring the knight into the game
King c4 Knight to d5 you go King Tubby
three and now Bishop to c1 you force the
King to go this way to read you to see
one square but now you get King gay to
Knights the c3 check and now here you
have the problem
the knight and Bishop control all of
these squares so if you came to a 1 the
King can no longer reach the sea to pawn
or the C 1 square the King will just
eliminate this pawn and well hopefully
not stalemated the black King and then
start pushing his a pond on the other
hand if you go King to b3 attack the
knight Knight captures on b5 you
eliminate this point
protect your pawn is protected and now
after the King moves again you will not
be able to do anything as the Bishop
covers the C 1 square and the a pawn
wins so a bit difficult to calculate in
in so very little time but it was
winning but Maxime doesn't go for it he
goes night to d4 wants to win the this
pawn this way Bishop to d3 defending and
now comes King to d5 Bishop to c4 check
King to c5 for bushel back to d3 and now
just King 2b for we have came to b6 King
to c3 and now butcher back to g6 and
here finally Maxime is able to win the
b5 point with a knife cut for some b5
check King to c5 and now comes a four we
have King to b6 and here again you have
to be careful if you play something like
King to b2 then you get King to a6 and
now even if you win the pawn let's say
Knight a three then we're gonna cover
what we've mentioned Knight captures on
C - you can just trade and even though
you have a pawn and your aqua bishop you
will not be able to win this game
because the point is of the wrong color
you have a queening happens on a light
Square and you have a dark square bishop
if you're interested in this we can just
show it very quickly let's say King b3
you want to March your King and pawn of
the boar King gate with let's say King
c4 King BA
King bee five now let's say King just
sticks to the corner a five King here
you can go King bee six came here pawn
comes to a six Kim b8 a seven check King
here and now of course you will have an
option since you don't have a way of
getting the King out of the corner as
you have a dark square bishop you can
either leave the King lose the pawn and
then it's draw by insufficient material
or are you gonna go King to a six and
now it's stalemate
the King has nowhere to go it's not
checkmate so therefore stalemate if
anyone was wondering why this is not
winning
so King to be four by maksim with King
to a six and now a five with Bishop to
e4
now comes Knight to c7 check finally
pushing the King away King to be seven
Knights the e6 now and Bishop to f5
attacking the knight Knights the c5
check King to c6 and now Bishop to e3
grabbing hold of this diagonal with rush
up to age seven Knights the b3 now and
King back to b7 with the shop to f4 King
to a6 and now Knight to c5 check
we have kinked a 7 and finally King to
b5 so a little by little white King
gaining activity blacking losing
activity with Bishop to f5 now comes a 6
Bishop to h3 and now King to a5 with
Bishop to f1 and now comes Bishop to e3
threatening some nasty discoveries about
the Black has black Roy doesn't have a
have a choice here he has to allow it
Bishop to e2 and now comes Knights the
e6 check and here Nakamura he didn't
lose on time but he placed his King on
b8 and here I don't know if he lost in
time or he resigned here but it's you
know but a position ready for
resignation because there's nothing to
do here but I think he's time actually
ran out doesn't really matter because
it's over just a 7 check if you move
your king then you will get a nice to be
in night to c7 check King has to move
and then you just promote to a queen
this is the easiest way to win okay I
mean black can capture it doesn't really
matter it's a completely winning well
whatever you do the bishop still covers
the C 1 square it's a pointless to
continue but yeah after this
after this came to be eight move the
game basically ended unmoved unmoved 98
so even though it's a lot going on it's
basically you know
maxime showing off his ability to
convert the winning end game into into
win but just that first part of the game
where so many checkmates were possible
and the maxime really shows off his
brilliant preparation skills this King
to g2 move just completely insane this
wow characteris 97 and now you know due
to all of these threats nakamura lost
most of his time and he basically played
this entire endgame which he almost
helped to a draw being a piece down
against against well at that time when
they were playing this I believe
magazine was even the highest rated
bullets player in live ratings in the
world here I prepared the standings
there you have it
cross and still number one in live
ratings in blitz twenty nine twenty two
point two eight but Maxima sheer behind
him in second place twenty nine to
twenty nine twenty one point four so
very close to him but at some point in
the tournament you can see that the
Carson lost thirty one point two points
in in Boyds and Maxine Soros or Maksim
won or lost 11.6 so none of them gained
any points but there are much higher
rated than everyone else and also it's
it's very nice if you're you know
interested in the boots ratings of the
players if you haven't seen it for for a
while so the top ten Crossan Maxine and
Kimura onion anypony she kirkenes
Svidler
Khurana Michael Adams and meteor and
raking the top ten so very very
interesting medium there we have it
I do hope you enjoyed it really really
an intense and insane game I would like
to thank Eliezer Birnbaum Gary Williams
Konstantinos locust Jeff Lewis and Rafa
Brusco for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
and thanks everyone for sending us your
ideas about the chess manga really where
we're really going through it one by one
there's a lot of them over 200 so it's
gonna take us a while but I am preparing
a separate Twitter account for the manga
series and everything I will keep you
informed and then you will be able to
follow everything that go
and whatever we create you're gonna be
of course the first to see it so thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day